turning ideas into action
the conference on the future of europe
has seen panels of ordinary citizens
formulate and deliver nearly 200
proposals on how to improve the eu
now they're being fine-tuned in
strasbourg where working groups brought
panel representatives together with
members of the european and national
parliaments eu institutions and civil
society they gave us a lot of concrete
issues for example about transparency
about the question that the language of
europe is sometimes bureaucratic and not
understandable the conference plenary
debated draft proposals on youth and
education and how to balance the economy
and social justice in the age of digital
transformation citizens challenged the
input of politicians and stakeholders
insisting their recommendations should
not be watered down although we as
citizens do welcome the many additions
to our recommendations
we do fear that our recommendations are
in risk of drowning in political agendas
plenary also examined new
recommendations on migration health and
climate change and debated the eu's
place in the world democracy rights and
values
there are a lot of good proposals but
some of them remain quite vague we need
to ensure
that we don't just produce proposals
where it will be too easy to dismiss
them after the conference plenui will
meet again to finalize conclusions to be
handed over to the presidents of the
european parliament commission and
council there is naturally still a lot
of work to do what i have as conclusion
of the work of the two last
days
is that we have found
together a method based on the
recommendations of the citizens
to come to real conclusions for this
conference
[Applause]
you